c'est le combat de toute une vie après
plus de six ans de lutte céline bouvet a
décidé d'arrêter son exploitation
agricole reprises à la suite de ses
parents en 1997
la raison un parc de huit éoliennes qui
provoque selon elle une surmortalité de
ces bêtes des troubles de leur
comportement mais aussi de fécondation
si l'éleveuse âgé de 46 ans a donc
renoncé à sa passion et à son métier
elle ne veut pas totalement tout perdre
et souhaite obtenir à minima des
indemnités céline a donc décidé de
porter plainte auprès de la commission
des requêtes de la cour de justice de la
république
j'ai porté plainte puisque c'était mon
dernier recours aussi un peu façon de
parler pour sauver les meubles
aujourd'hui si j'arrête mon exploitation
sans porter plainte je pars avec pénates
donc on perd tout comme ça en portant
plainte
on aura peut-être je dis bien peut-être
la possibilité d'obtenir au niveau
niveau préjudice on sait 23 ans de ma
vie qui partent en l'air ce que chez
obligés de faire des choix
quand on est éleveur on n'est pas là
pour voir souffrir vont crever les
animaux là comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure mais animaux ne veulent plus
fécondes et donc c'est très compliqué
qui veut dire plus de plus de vous plus
de l'est derrière donc
voilà je peux pas non plus vite sur mon
exploitation qu'avec du fois où j'ai
fait un choix il ya un an d'arrêter mon
activité laitière c'était je me suis
mangé le clinquant sont visés par cette
plainte le premier ministre jean castex
le ministre de la santé olivier véran
l'actuel ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire barbara pompili
et sa prédécesseure elisabeth bornes
l'agricultrice les attaque en justice
pour complicité par aide à
l'administration de substances nocives à
titre principal et omission de combattre
un sinistre
à titre subsidiaire les ministres ont
tous étaient informées et personne n'a
réagi
et pourquoi personne n'a réagi parce que
c'est encore apprendre vidéo logique
très français qui est celui de
l'éolienne on ne touche pas à l'éolienne
on n'applique pas le principe de
précaution est ici ce que nous disons
nous disant vous vous êtes abstenu de
combattre un sinistre le sinistre et en
ce que subit adam bouvet et vous auriez
plus le combattre ne serait-ce qu'en
suspendant l'éolien de temps d'une
investigation
quand il te couper les éoliennes au lieu
de ça ce que vous avez fait c'est que
vous avez multiplié sur le territoire
national les éoliennes et dans la sphère
de madame bouvet vous avez été alertée
de la situer sur ta de la politique
sévit droit vous êtes au courant qu'il
ya un problème là spécifiquement je veux
dire et vous n'avez rien fait et le
problème c'est que madame bouvet on a
retrouvé sur elle dans son corps sur
l'organisme authentifier des métaux
lourds qui vont qui sont en train petit
à petit la tuer et concrètement vous le
savez on vous l'a dit on vous a transmis
les éléments vous n'en faites rien
depuis 2013 une quarantaine de bêtes
sont mortes dans l'exploitation de
céline où il ne reste que vingt vaches
entre juillet et la mi octobre 2020 des
inspecteurs mandatés par le ministère de
l'agriculture et le ministère de la
transition écologique sont venus sur
place
un rapport de cette visite est toujours
attendu depuis fin janvier